good morning John it's day I don't know
what day it's Wednesday wait I already
filmed an intro I should use that quick
it'll be right behind me here it is it's
a cheese wagon I'm already done I wasn't
as fast as I expected to go but that's a
big wagon huh I'm a faker this is easier
okay so along with my new camera I got a
green screen so now I can do this only
you can prevent forest fires
quick mail black red green oh right hmm
I'm Superman
bombs beautiful cars
Wolverine Margo Roth Spiegelman cows
birds flying dolphins swimming elephants
frolicking giraffes uh Neil Gaiman
jean-luc Picard Hundertwasser ah oh nice
this is nice that's very nice I don't
even know what it is I'm gonna put it in
later but that's nice that's probably
enough of that green skis are fun you
can get one different think I'm gonna do
it'll be so much fun so if you were
wondering what it for my birthday
Catherine took me to go see Spamalot
it's the newest extension of the Monty
Python franchise Monty Python goes to
Broadway and as you might expect that
was pretty good we had to go to Spokane
to see it we went in our new Civic and
we saw geese and this waterfall I love
green screens as of today you can go see
whether to things that I do with the
green screen right now it is at
youtube.com slash the Eco geek I and the
Eco geek and at the channel I will be
discussing all kinds of environmental
news mostly focusing on green technology
Hey look you can see the channel page
behind me right now Hey look up there on
the channel page there's a subscribe
button maybe you should go click on that
answer what else I'm gonna do with the
green screen I'm not really sure
personally John I was a big fan of your
what would you do with ho bus video
wouldn't it be great if nerdfighters
left in comments ideas for what to do
with my green screen yeah that would be
great maybe someone will tell them to do
that to it let me know what you think of
youtube.com slash of the ego geek and
leave me suggestions for what would I do
what would I do what would I do with a
green screen John dftba